at the storm and broadcasting unit they
are ready but the latest brexit battle
could overshadow the first scheduled
meeting of the new northern ireland
assembly the dup has not committed to
full participation on these benches so
the uk government is threatening to
override the irish sea border if
necessary
and we will continue to talk with the eu
but we will not let that stand in the
way of protecting peace and stability in
northern ireland
as both the prime minister and the
foreign secretary have made clear
we will take action to protect the
belfast good friday agreement if
solutions cannot be found but the vice
president of the european commission
says the uk government should be honest
about having agreed the protocol
honesty about what the uk sign up to is
needed
honesty about the fact that the eu
cannot solve all the problems created by
brexit and the type of racism that the
uk government chose that is the reason
for which the position of the eu has
been consistent we will not renegotiate
the protocol the dup is dismissing sinn
fein's demand that a government be
formed its leader will remain an mp and
not moved to stormont until he can see a
way through
given the statement that the foreign
secretary has made it is evident that
the likelihood of agreement between the
uk and the eu in the short term
is uh remote and so i think it is
incumbent now upon the government to act
and to do so quickly
the british government are playing a
game of checking with the european
commission and we're caught out in the
middle because we are being held around
them because of their actions that is
not acceptable to the public here i am
angered for the public here who want
government here who wants an executive
who want money in their pockets and they
want us to fix the health service it may
seem insurmountable but they've overcome
greater challenges and all sides know
the only path to resolution is
compromise
this is an issue on two levels firstly
the practicalities of the protocol how
does the eu protect its single market
here and secondly the politics of the
protocol because this war of words is
now stifling the power-sharing
government that was devised to maintain
peace brexit and the resulting sea
border have upset the delicate political
balance but there's huge public pressure
to get down to the business of governing
david blevins sky news in belfast